Speaker 1: All right, we have so much to cover
today that I'm not even going to waste time
talking about the world famous benefits of
membership, I'm going to skip that and jump
right into material because there's just too
much to cover.
And this is really interesting economically.
We have all over the map opinions about a
recent statement by Joe Biden about so-called
free riders on the unemployment insurance
enhanced unemployment insurance that is currently
available now for framing, for context.
Any social insurance program has the possibility
of free riders, people on food stamps who
shouldn't really get them.
But they're using business expenses to artificially
lower their incomes so that they qualify for
food stamps or whatever, or people who choose
not to work or not work as much in order to
qualify for Medicaid instead of working and
earning more and paying for their health insurance,
for example.
Now, no honest person who understands any
social insurance program will tell you that
free riders don't exist.
They do exist.
But the point is, when we think about macroeconomics
instead of the micro of such programs, if
the programs are finely tuned, if the benefits
are well calibrated, if the means testing
is appropriate and enforced, assuming it's
a means tested program, you basically don't
worry about a few anecdotal free riders because
they are relatively few.
And the program overall at the societal level,
at the macroeconomic level is a positive thing
for the economy.
That's the general approach to any properly
administered social insurance program.
Right now we do have a unique circumstances
with so-called enhanced unemployment benefits
through the federal government during the
pandemic.
Now, normally, unemployment insurance and
benefits are a state thing.
States determine the level of benefits.
They vary by state.
They tend to be higher in states with higher
wages and higher cost of living.
And that's fine.
And that's how it all works in this case.
And this is a very rare situation because
of the pandemic, the federal government came
in and they dropped an enhancement on people,
in many cases disconnected from what they
were earning in the job they lost due to the
pandemic.
So you can always say there are some people
choosing unemployment insurance instead of
working.
We don't worry about it because unemployment
insurance runs out.
The benefits aren't huge.
There is not that many people who even could
earn more from the unemployment insurance
than from working.
It's also just a truth about humans that people
generally want to feel useful and they want
to work.
So while sure, anecdotally, there might be
some people in normal circumstances that have
figured out a way to earn the same or almost
the same from staying home, it's not really
a macroeconomic concern in this particular
moment because of the enhanced federal unemployment,
there are more people who theoretically could
earn a little more from staying home and collecting
the normal state unemployment benefits, plus
the enhanced federal benefits then from going
back to the job that they had, that that is
theoretically possible right now and anecdotally
it's happening.
So Joe Biden gave a series of remarks yesterday
on the economy and talked about how jobs numbers
from April were short of what was expected.
And one reason that's being cited is that
because of this enhanced unemployment, there
are more people than usual turning down jobs
so that they can stay home and collect that
sweet, sweet, enhanced unemployment.
So Joe Biden says he's going to deal with
that.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Look, fifth thing we're going to
do, we're going to make it clear that anyone
collecting unemployment was offered a suitable
job must take the job or lose their unemployment
benefits.
There are a few covid-19 related exceptions
so that people aren't forced to choose between
their basic safety and a paycheck.
But otherwise, that's the law.
Speaker 1: Now, there are already a ton of
things to talk about here.
First of all, as Joe Biden says, this is already
the law.
All of these unemployment systems in each
state, sometimes it's by phone, sometimes
it's online.
There's different ways that it's done.
You regularly have to answer questions like,
are you looking for a job?
Did you apply for jobs?
Have you been interviewed?
Were you offered a job that you turned down?
So Joe Biden is not creating any new law here.
Joe Biden is saying we're going to enforce
the rules on unemployment.
Interesting.
It's really difficult to enforce.
People are self reporting.
There's relatively little confirmation or
oversight.
There's no central database.
Where the government could determine you said
you weren't offered any jobs, but you were
offered one and you declined it, it's basically
the honor system.
So this is really just kind of like a message
from Joe Biden.
I don't really know how much will be done
as a result of it.
But let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 2: I know there's been a lot of discussion
since Friday, since Friday's report that people
are being paid to stay home rather than go
to work.
Well, we don't see much evidence of that.
That is a major factor.
We don't see that.
Look, it's easy to say the line has been because
of the generous unemployment benefits.
That is a major factor in labor shortages.
Americans want to work.
Americans want to work, as my dad used to
say, jobs about a lot more than a paycheck.
It's about your dignity, your place in the
community, being able to look your kid the
eye and say everything's going to be OK.
I think the people who claim Americans won't
work, even if they find a good and fair opportunity,
underestimate the American people.
So we'll insist that the law is followed with
respect to benefits, but we're not going to
turn our backs on our fellow Americans.
22 million people lost their jobs in this
pandemic through no fault of their own.
They lost their jobs to a virus and to a government
that bungled its response to the crisis and
failed to protect them.
We still have eight million fewer jobs than
we did when the pandemic started.
Speaker 1: OK, so you get the idea.
So there have been two reactions to this.
One reaction has been great.
Get these freeloaders off of unemployment.
You have restaurants, you have other businesses
that can't find workers.
So the story goes because people are happier
staying home and making enhanced unemployment
rather than going back into work.
The reality is this is statistically rare.
It's possible because of enhanced unemployment.
There are anecdotes about it.
But I worry that by even doing this, Joe Biden
is buying into this right wing narrative that
we have no particular reason to except we
don't have to accept that right wing narrative.
But there's another side to this which many
people are reacting with.
If the wages are so low at these jobs that
you do make more staying home on unemployment.
Isn't that a sign that maybe the wages are
too low, raise the wages in order to attract
employees?
Now, remember, this is not normally as much
of an issue when there is not the enhanced
unemployment.
This is really a transient issue.
Enhanced unemployment from the federal government
is going to be ending in all likelihood later
this year.
But what does it say about the wages being
paid?
Another practical difficulty is Biden says,
you know, you can't turn down a suitable job
and continue to collect unemployment.
Who determines if it's suitable?
If you lost a job making sixty five thousand
dollars and you're offered one making thirteen
dollars an hour, is that suitable?
Do you lose unemployment benefits if you don't
accept that job?
So I think that this is basically unenforceable.
I'm curious to see what enforcement there
will be.
I think enhanced unemployment is going to
end before there is any real enforcement.
And much of the problem is that I see Joe
Biden by doing this as playing into a Republican
criticism, which is barely valid.
Again, any social insurance program, anecdotally,
you can find instances of anything.
The question is, at a macro level, is that
actually a drag on the program?
Enhanced unemployment has been a huge saving
grace for so many people.
And my concern is Biden's just buying into
it too much.
And it's not really the problem that Republicans
claim it to be.
Let me know what you think